sur la base d'informations et
partenaires très partiels ont créé une
vérité une ce qu'on appelle
techniquement une aisance cognitives sur
le fait que le poutine est un indicateur
que bachar al assad est un monstre que
omar el bachir est un génocidaire et c
est ça devient ça entre dans le discours
habituel le discours officiel le
discours standards qu'on trouve dans les
médias et finalement ça n'étonne plus
personne et plus personne ne se pose des
questions sur des chiffres comme deux
cent mille îles ou quatre cent mille
morts au darfour
et alors que personne n'a vérifié ces
chiffres et je suis bien placé pour
savoir parce que moi même à la tête de
du renseignement ou au soudan colon 2
ans j'ai je me suis attaché à compter
ses morts et on n'est jamais arrivé à
200 milles est arrivé au maximum à 2500
morts
donc on a créé pour différentes raisons
politiques surtout géostratégique aussi
on a créé effectivement une sorte de
fausse réalité qui facilite entre
guillemets comme vous l'avez dit des
prises de décisions qui sont à
l'encontre en fait du droit
international pour se justifier de cette
manière
[Musique]